my name is Matt Bailey I've been in the
search engine optimization industry for
well over 20 years and I've also trained
and consulted with some of the world's
biggest brands I've done training and
taught digital analytics digital
marketing search engine optimization and
many other subjects to Google Procter &
Gamble Johnson & Johnson Microsoft IBM
Experian Disney and many other brands
I've also written three books on the
subject of online marketing you can find
internet marketing an hour a day wired
to be wowed and teach new dogs old
tricks this is advanced search engine
optimization an introduction to the
course in this module I'm going to cover
what you will learn by taking this
course
search engine optimization is a powerful
way to increase the visibility of your
business at its most basic search engine
optimization is about increasing the
rankings of your website at its most
complex it is managing the programming
content visibility and success of a
website and much more search engines are
the primary way that people find
information if you are not visible in
the search engines then your customers
won't find you
search engine optimization enables you
to know what your customers want and it
enables you to be found
search engine optimization has changed
over the years and some early methods
are not only ineffective but could get
you into trouble with the search engines
because of this it is important to keep
up to date on the latest information and
continually increase your knowledge and
skills search engine optimization is the
number one activity for successful
businesses as it all starts with search
developing skills in this area will
enable you to provide an invaluable
service to companies and also provide a
base for additional skills related to
search engine optimization the
objectives for this course are that
you'll learn basic to advanced skills
for search engine optimization you'll
understand how search engines work and
know multiple research methods for
effective data collection apply research
concepts to market your website
successfully employ best practices and
techniques to promote search engine
rankings of your website manage your
website and troubleshoot problems
effectively measure the success of your
website and increase your skill set with
website analytics
in this practitioner course the content
will be broken down in these areas
looking at how search engines work
understanding how human factors are
related to Houston to look deeply at the
foundation of keywords and how to use
those keywords in both on-page and
off-page optimization obviously you're
going to have to learn some technical
programming and some technical tricks to
help you manage your website more
effectively and make it more friendly
for search engines and then we're going
to look specifically at marketing your
business marketing your business online
especially if you have a local business
there are many opportunities available
to you but also some planning as far as
building a new website redesigning your
current website and additional changes
I'll walk you through the steps for a
marketing plan and then ultimately how
to measure everything what's working why
it's working and how to react to that
let's look at our first section we're
going to spend some time understanding
how search engines work do you ever
wonder why the search engines present
the results the way they do everything
from the colors the words the
arrangement of the content has gone
through scrutiny in order to present the
most pleasing relevant results that is
designed to get you to enjoy the user
experience and so we're going to look at
how the search results are produced the
factors that influence the rankings
within search engines and the algorithm
the algorithm is the mathematical
formula that determines which pages are
ranked higher than others we're also
going to look at how a search engine
sees your website and how those search
results are designed to get you to click
or stay on the search results
what's vitally important is
understanding the human connection to
search engines you see the search
engine's primary customer is the human
the searcher and so the search results
are made specifically to connect to your
brain and there are factors that make us
pay attention and click and help decide
on which results are more relevant than
others and ultimately it comes down to
the importance of words now because
words are so important we are going to
spend a lot of time on understanding
keywords keywords are the words that
people type into the search engine and
so that is the foundation of all online
marketing you will do the skills you
develop through this course of
understanding researching organizing and
developing keywords in your marketing
content are going to spill over in other
areas that will help you be a better
marketer and will help you build your
online business more effectively you can
use these same skills in paid search in
social marketing buying ads writing
content and developing multimedia the
reason why words are so important is
that shows us the intent of our searcher
when we understand the intent of the
searcher that helps us better understand
what they need and so we can write our
content and adjust it to fit what the
searcher needs we're going to cover how
to use keyword tools to build and gather
keyword lists and then how you can
evaluate them for more effectiveness
going to take those keywords and through
the on-page optimization section you'll
understand better how to implement those
keywords into your content into your
website and we'll look at the key areas
the key elements of the page that are
most important and then also your
content structure how you present your
content sometimes just as important is
what's on the page we'll look at the
navigation and the type of content
that's important to optimize based on
being an e-commerce site a publisher a
blogger whatever type of content you
might have and then how to avoid
penalties in the search engines in the
off page optimisation section we're
primarily going to look at link building
easy search engine algorithms take in
two very important account how many
links come to your site but not only how
many how quality those links are meaning
links from sites are not equal some
sites have a higher influence than other
sites and so we're going to look at the
types of Link's that you can get we're
going to evaluate those links how to
optimize them and how to build links
through many different media and
opportunities and then how to use
software there are linked tools out
there that will help you maintain and
manage the links coming to your site as
well as give you ideas for additional
link building
there are also some programming know-how
you've got to employ in order to make
your site friendlier for search engines
everything from the URL structure how
you link pages and maybe how you
redirect pages from a previous version
of your website these are all the little
details that add up and you just have to
know how to do these things we're going
to provide an overview of most of the
problems you'll encounter but also point
you in the direction of some of the
tools that are available through the
search engines themselves to help make
this a little bit easier
now if you are a local business as I
said there is a lot available to you
through the search engines to enhance
your listings in the search engines of
results you can get additional business
listings you will have maps click to
call functionality and additional
measurements that you can use to show
the effectiveness of your online
marketing and of course not every
website stays the same there is always
things that you need to do in order to
grow your site whether it's building a
new website and choosing a new domain
name or redesigning your current site
also what to do if there might be a
problem we'll have a troubleshooting
section as well to help you figure out
what might be going wrong most
importantly we're going to look at
building a marketing plan for your
business going beyond the rankings and
looking at what all we can do to improve
the effectiveness of our businesses
online I'll show you how to do some
competitive assessments but also how to
manage a team and/or if your individual
how your job affects other people in the
marketing department or in the business
of the website ultimately then we're
also going to look at how to protect
yourself from further updates from
search engines and their algorithm
updates of course you want to protect
yourself and not get on the wrong side
of a search engine
otherwise you may find your website has
been taken out of the results
with analytics we'll look to see what
you can measure to show true success of
all your efforts you're putting in a lot
of work with optimization and doing a
lot of these changes so obviously you'll
want to be able to show some result of
your work analytics will provide the
numbers you need as well as factors that
will help you understand what you can do
to continue your improvement not just to
improve rankings but to improve your
overall business online well these are
the things that we're going to cover in
this course it's going to be pretty
extensive there's going to be a lot of
information and it's going to be
challenging there are resources that
will be available to help you get
through this but ultimately it will be
very rewarding in that you will be able
to understand the primary activities
that are necessary to increase your
visibility in the search engine rankings
to manage your site more effectively and
also market your business online in
order to be profitable based on all of
the work that is contained in this
course